12 11
10. so june 29th 2007 we were excited we
were terrified
[Music]
it's a happy moment but it's also a
stressful one what's going to happen
when it goes out into the world
we don't know what's about to come this
is a totally new experience and
something that's going to change our
lives forever
[Music]
it was amazing i mean it still it just
kind of gives me a little bit of a good
sponsor because it was it was history
a lot of nervousness
a lot of stomach ache
a lot of excitement
i'm lauren schmick and i'm jason schmick
and our son noah was born the same day
the very first iphone was released
this is the story of the iphone baby and
how 15 years shaped a generation
[Music]
try to remember life before the iphone
it's hard but noah schmick literally
can't
because well he's never lived a day in
the world without an iphone
but this isn't just about one teenager
who shares his birthday with a
world-changing piece of glass and metal
i used to post this on your birthday
every year it's because it's steve jobs
wishing you a happy birthday because
look at this yeah you got the cake and
your and your birthday and that number's
right there was personalized he cared
this is about how over the last 15 years
the iphone itself went from a baby to a
teen as it grew and developed so did our
dependence on it noah's generation is
the most extreme representation of that
dependence because they've never known
life without it
it's a generation that fears being
disconnected this is everything you'd
ever need in the palm of your hands why
would you never be off of it they have
some of the world's entire knowledge and
all of your closest people instantly
available to talk to if you gave this
thing to a caveman they'd like they'd
freak out
of course today it's not just the iphone
it's all smartphones galaxy s22 ultra
breaks all the rules of what a
smartphone can do legacy phone makers
such as samsung nokia and blackberry
creator rim were forced to adapt or die
after the introduction of the iphone so
you thought blackberries were all
business well it was google's android
operating system
combined with more affordable phones
from samsung and others that captured
the biggest global market share it was
apple's iphone that really kicked off
the mobile revolution
so i set out to pinpoint the major
developments of the iphone that led to
that dependence with exclusive access to
apple executives past and present who
made this revolutionary
product alongside those conversations i
went to wisconsin hi joanna and i traced
the story of noah his twin 13 year old
siblings and his parents
just like millions of other families
apple's invention made them more
connected and disconnected in ways no
one anticipated
look baby's first picture
and this blob is his head but look at he
has his hand up by his face and that's
exactly how he was born with this hand
while noah was in development apple was
developing its own baby over 2100 miles
away the start of the iphone project
happened from the ipod project we
started seeing
these feature phones with cameras
starting to add digital music features
100 tunes in your phone baby hello moto
and it was clear at some point
they might be able to catch up with us
you know with this lead that we had with
the ipod imagine a phone that is all
music on one side and all talk on the
other just like you the mobile phone
wanted to have everything it wanted to
be all in one device at the time we were
also saying okay what is the future of
the ipod and if people have two devices
in their hands which one would they pick
up every time after tony fidel
co-invented the ipod steve jobs had a
new task for him and a few others in
early 2005 figure out what an apple
phone would look like
one was a ipod plus phone which looked
like an ipod classic
it had the wheel on it we tried for
weeks
six eight weeks to try to crack the code
on that we couldn't make it work there
was another project and we were doing in
the ipod team we were making a full
screen ipod and the full screen ipod was
we were playing videos at the time on
the ipod but it was in a smaller screen
then over in the world of
the mac they were making multi-touch
technology all three of those things
came together over time to create what
we know as the iphone today
we're introducing
three
revolutionary products of this class by
january 2007 it was ready to show the
world a widescreen ipod with touch
controls
a revolutionary mobile phone
and a breakthrough internet
communications device
these are not
three separate devices
this is one device
and we are calling it
iphone
my group that i work with we were all
big mac fanatics
every one of us our jaws just hit the
floor we're like this is the coolest
thing we've ever seen i i just i knew i
had to have one but instead of standing
in line for that very first iphone jason
schmick grabbed his digital camera ipod
and blackberry and headed to the
birthing center right after he fired off
an email to his colleagues well i titled
it red alert it looks like the iphone
isn't the only thing being released
today i will not be in today lauren went
to labor last night around 6 p.m in
madison the iphone and noah were
released to the world here he is
everyone
noah harrison schmidt was there anything
surprising to you as the phone gets out
into the world about how it starts to be
used the culture at apple changed
dramatically because the people who had
them they were always messaging or they
were always
emailing when people were in the
meetings they were doing this all the
time it became a constant deluge of
emails and messages and you were like oh
my god no one could get off of them and
you were like something's different here
but messaging phone calls and music
weren't the end game what came next
really changed things
as we arrive at iphone's first birthday
we're gonna take it to the next level
and today we're introducing the iphone
3g
the year i got my first iphone was
2008 and it was the 3g so it looked
something like this oh my god yes
i forgot how uh
how curved the bottom was the second
iphone had a faster 3g connectivity that
speed combined with a new software
feature turned the iphone into something
more than a phone there's an app for
that
in 2008 the iphone 3g brought faster 3g
networking and the revolutionary app
store greg joswiak was part of a small
team steve jobs tasked with rolling out
the iphone to the masses
he now leads marketing for apple you
know the other great innovation was in
2008 it was the app store that is what
created this massive set of things that
is what changed our lives right they
didn't all just come from us they came
from what we did to empower developers
when i joined apple in march 2009 there
were roughly about eight thousand six
thousand apps submitted per week i mean
it had grown quickly oh yes the store
exploded beyond apple's expectations and
so the company hired phillip shoemaker
to oversee it
2008 christmas one developer made a
million dollars and that
it issued a gold rush to everybody and
developers started submitting in mass
when the app store launched apple
actually expected maybe 500 apps by
april we were at 25 000 apps per week
there were all kinds of apps ones that
would turn your phone into a flashlight
a restaurant critic a personalized dj
and loads that would well turn your
phone into a babysitter we started to
hand noah the phone
shortly after the twins came along so he
was you know two
maybe three be entertained for a minute
at a restaurant or
i
am breastfeeding you know he knew where
the page of
games was that he was allowed to play
and even if it was a hit the chicken and
it makes a chicken sound
to him that was the greatest thing in
the whole world i never thought the kids
apps would take off the iphone was for
those of us that have been in the in in
the phone space for a while seemingly
kind of difficult to use right people
didn't understand how to swipe how to
input text etc etc but i was wrong
the days of bringing toys and books and
crayons to the restaurant were over now
games and apps were just a tap away but
that instant gratification had some
unforeseen
and expensive consequences
in 2009 late 2009 my daughter is five
years old her name is miley she started
playing smurfs a lot about a month later
we realized that she had purchased 450
worth of
credits smurf berries
so we instituted something we called the
miley rule which was a feature in the
operating system that allowed the parent
to turn off
purchases saying requires a password
every time by the time noah's generation
was four or five they were immersed in
digital worlds that almost felt real as
for the real world big leaps in the
iphone's camera were starting to give
them a whole new way to see it we set
out to create an all new phone a camera
in the iphone 4s
we didn't set our sights and just making
it better than every other phone we've
already done that we set our sights on
competing with the quality of many great
point-and-shoot cameras
this one part where you like start
really shaking shaking your butt
[Laughter]
you literally dance like that for the
whole song
and still we're not tired
i mean it's no idea your first kid you
take a photo of him doing anything and
because you think everything they do
is amazing i think the other thing that
that really
kicked it into high gear for us using
the camera was when facebook became an
app because
that was how we shared everything with
my family and my parents wanted to see
photos of of our kids all the time
[Music]
with faster uploading and improved
social media apps noah decided he wanted
to be in more than just family photos
i started watching youtube when i was
like six or seven i wanted to be a
youtuber very badly and did you ever try
to shoot videos on your
your parents iphones or your phone yeah
i would drag my parents out to
record these like terrible terrible like
tutorial videos for just toys i got for
like holidays he's kind of big
even though
on the back he's all stuffy but soon
kids wouldn't even need their parents to
hold the camera anymore the next phone
has a front-facing camera
and we
are trying to figure out what do you do
with the front-facing camera and you can
take a picture with the front facing
camera you take a picture of yourself
is that going to be big i don't know it
was it ends up being spoiler big deal
justin santa maria was a senior engineer
at apple working on ios and led the team
that launched facetime in 2010
i remember having the vice president of
our of iphone come to my desk and say
steve wants to see a demo what's really
funny is steve's kind of looking he's
holding his phone like this looking down
and i remember this he goes i look
abominable it's ultimately not how
people hold their phones today for for
selfies or video calls that's right not
even steve jobs saw the impact of the
front-facing camera coming
noah though has grown up surrounded by
kids and adults with outstretched arms
i do not
like to take selfies of myself because i
don't understand the appeal fully but my
siblings definitely do they take photos
themselves all the time they'll do like
an interlocked arm thing like one thing
you can fix for the other one
i went on vacation
and you saw people just taking selfies
all day long on vacation when you're at
a resort or whatever and they're not
enjoying the world around them you're
like wait a second what's going on here
we are disintermediating reality with
this screen in front of your face i
think it's just
society has trained them to take
pictures of themselves the iphone was no
longer just a phone it was a powerful
connected computer with a camera but one
thing held this device back from being
something we could do more and more on
today
we are launching
the biggest advancement in the history
of iphone the iphone 6
and the iphone 6 plus
and yes they're bigger they're a lot
bigger by 2014 the smartphone
competition was huge literally check out
the screen this thing is huge pretty
massive android phone makers especially
samsung samsung that says samsung began
packing as much into these phones as
possible and with that the phone started
getting bigger would you mind moving
your enormous phone
you mean the enormously awesome galaxy
thinking back at that time how big of a
factor was samsung and android as they
were hitting the market with these
massive phones they were annoying and
they were annoying because as you know
they ripped off our technology they took
the innovations that we had created and
created a
poor copy of it and just put a bigger
screen around it and you know so yeah we
were not too pleased apple sued samsung
for patent infringement and by the end
of the decade apple had received
hundreds of millions for the patent
violations
a samsung spokeswoman said the company
has pioneered many mobile industry
firsts even in the rain the shower or
the pool including large oled displays
and water and dust resistant devices
by 2014 apple finally caved and the
iphone was now the size of a samsung
because jason and millions of others saw
the benefit of giant phones and yeah i
love this thing man i and i said i was
never going to use a phone with a screen
this big
two years later shortly after noah
turned 11 jason handed that 6s plus down
to his son i was very excited when i got
my first iphone like it was probably
one of
the
happiest moments of my life i just
remember
like getting it and then just like
running away immediately to go like play
stuff because a lot of my experience
with phone games was at that point from
like watch just watching my dad yes for
noah it meant games well even more games
he'd already played on his computer and
gaming console but now it was always
with him his very own iphone
plants vs zombies was a huge one for me
minecraft pocket edition like a lot of
like the original phone games like
flappy bird
angry birds is a huge one
i would say by the time noah was 10
he was
pretty fully ingrained in like the video
game world it has never been
my favorite thing and it is something
that half of us have have tried to set
limits on
during the late 2010s the iphone not
only grew in size but in processing
power
more power equaled more capabilities
on my phone now which is this one i
mostly just like watch youtube and
listen to music i play games and like
browse reddit and stuff but i don't
really use it for phone stuff i see it's
just a small computer in my pocket
after all that there wasn't much left to
do to make the iphone more prevalent in
our lives well other than make it do all
those things for even longer
we are so excited to tell you that with
iphone 11 pro you now get up to four
hours longer in your day
and
with iphone 11 pro max up to five hours
longer today
battery life is always important for a
portable product we've made it even a
bigger and bigger you know point of
emphasis whether it means making the
silicon more efficient our ability to
where we can increase the size of a
battery and certainly larger screen
iphones allow you to do that
ahead of his 15th birthday noah's
parents finally upgraded his iphone 6s
plus to a new iphone 13. this is cool
dad thank you
the biggest difference is definitely
battery life
like a on this phone i could probably
only play a game for like two hours
before i have to plug it in this one i
can play a game for an entire day and
still like get home after school day and
be at like 50 battery it's amazing it's
so much nicer do you have a sense of how
much time you spend on your phone i feel
like not
a healthy amount that's chloe one of
noah's 13 year old siblings who is
especially attached to her iphone 12 and
apps like tick tock and snapchat i kind
of feel like i'm always on a device
besides when i go like hanging out with
friends and even then i'm like on my
phone sometimes
but like i'm mostly
on my phone and stuff like all of us the
schmicks have enjoyed each of those
life-changing innovations that have come
along with the last 15 years of the
iphone but now possibly the greatest
innovation apple can give us limiting
how much we use it
screen time empowers you with both
insight and control over how you spend
your time we think this is going to be
helpful for many people but especially
for some kids we use screen time a lot
to limit how much time they get with
certain things
so it you know having it locked down
during the school day so they're not
using it at school which they're not
supposed to do anyways and at night to
force them to actually go to sleep yes
it doesn't they don't they just simply
don't work between the hours of nine to
six a.m or something like that we try
you know we're always
chloe especially we definitely get a lot
of time requests throughout the day okay
all right it's about time and usually
followed by a text message that says my
teacher said i can have 15 minutes can i
please have 15 minutes here we go that's
pretty
i've been talking to
a child who was born on june 29 2007.
this is him
oh that's his picture from june 29th
2016. take him with the iphone not taken
with the iphone yes you'll learn but
this is something he said to me during
our interview a couple weeks ago he says
this is everything you would ever need
in the palm of your hands why would you
ever be off of it is that what you hope
to hear or does some part of that make
you feel uncomfortable it's mixed right
we've created an incredible tool
to help people with how they learn and
tell people how they work you know to
help people with how they communicate
how they're how they're entertained it's
a powerful tool but the same same time
we want to help people with the fact
that there's moderation needed but we
don't make our money off engagement
right there's no like more you use your
iphone the more money we make that isn't
the way it works right we just want you
to have this great experience and some
say sometimes that does mean you've got
to temper how much you're going to use
you got to moderate how much you want to
use this have you seen this with some of
your own kids we all have concerns
around social media and the effect on
kids my younger
daughter yeah no she's she and i have
talked about it and she goes through
periods where
she's using it too much and then scales
herself way back
truly we just thought this was going to
be a fun easy to use thing when you want
to do a few messages didn't think it was
going to become the center of your life
we have burgers we have fries kind of we
have i don't think there's an asparagus
there is there is
there we go all right
after 15 years of living with the iphone
we now have to figure out how to live
with it less
in theory we have a no phones at the
table for dinner
if we've learned anything from all this
it's that our individual willpower is
only challenged by increasing
technological advancements
it's always amazing that every time you
think it's as good as it can get we
always try to you know manage a way to
make it better but if and when that
better thing comes
will we control it or will it control us
as i've grown older i've gotten
way way way more into these things as so
as the rest of the world
they've gotten a lot better and they're
gonna keep getting
insanely good taking away screens is
like taking away my friends no one can
stop you from being on your phone at all
times besides your own self-discipline